hallo falls ich will karen löhnert ort
mit ich stehe endlich in meiner küche
meiner küche ist zwar noch gar nicht
fertig also es fehlt auf der rückwand es
fehlen noch meine lampe meine lichter es
fehlt eigentlich noch ziemlich viel aber
ich kann hier endlich wieder kochen und
backen und deswegen habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen endlich auch wieder aus
meiner eigenen küche raus zu filmen
obwohl sie noch nicht fertig ist und ich
habe ganz viele tolle und leckere
grillrezepte für euch wir haben heute
eine kleine familienfeier bei uns und
ich habe ganz viele queen rezepte
vorbereitet die ich euch heute und
morgen im laufe des tages zeigen werde
und hochladen werte ist nämlich ganz
viele kleine videos entstanden ich
wollte kein großes video machen sondern
so kann sich jeder aussuchen was er
gerne sehen möchte und nächste woche
gibt es dann noch mal ganz viele
grillrezepte da wird dann auch die
national wieder kommen meine freundin
vielleicht kennt das noch vom letzten
jahr
und die wird uns ein ganz leckeres
rezept zeigen
ich zeige euch einfach mal hier kurz was
ich gemacht habe hier habe ich zum
beispiel lange spiesse gemacht die sind
total lecker die schmeißen wird auch
gleich auf den grill zu den langen
spiessen gehört hier dieser zwiebel
salat 4 peter also türkisches fladenbrot
ganz lecker hier habe ich humus gemacht
in kichererbsen pury mit etwas
sesampaste hier sind ein paar hühnchen
spieße mit joghurt marinade hier ein
leckerer auberginen salat und hier hatte
ich gestern das hatte ich gestern
gemacht haben auch gestern schon
gegessen und zwar ist es so ein rotes
tomaten salsa und das habe ich mit
gegrillten auberginen und mit gegrillten
zucchinis angerichtet und hier war eben
noch ein leckerer grünen salat wie es
gehen könnte
den habe ich nicht als video gemacht
weiß nicht wen ich sowie die auf wunsch
können das kleine in kommentaren
schreiben
ansonsten lasse ich weg und diese
rezepte muss ich jetzt natürlich alle
noch fertig machen also die videos
fertig schneiden und dann werden sie für
euch hochgeladen und vielleicht habt ihr
noch ein rezept was ihr euch wünscht das
dürfte gern streifen das kann ich dann
nächste woche mit aufnehmen lassen auf
jeden fall einen kommentar auf irgendwie
was gefehlt hat dann kann ich das alles
noch mit einbauen
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall einen
ganz schönen tag wir werden jetzt
grillen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal tschüss